the other thing would be if
a completely superior design
for a new sort of state independent
monetary system emerged
but it's really hard to even imagine how
that would come to emerge
and there's good reasons to think that
bitcoin
the conditions of its launch were
extremely favorable and hard to
replicate
can you speak to some of those
conditions why it's a unique uh
timing wise uh moment for bitcoin to
emerge
yeah so obviously bitcoin was born in
the depths of the financial crisis which
gives it a nice
nice historical element but that was
kind of a coincidence honestly we know
that satoshi had been working on it
earlier in back or in 2017.
um the really special thing about
bitcoin was that
it was launched anonymously by an entity
that did not seek any glory or credit
for what they did
and apparently never monetized it at all
so they never really
moved any of their coins satoshi sent
one test transaction
uh hal finney who's one of the earliest
bitcoiners
aside from that as far as we know
satoshi never spent any of their coins
so you have this wonderful promethean
quality
whereby it's almost self-sacrificial i
mean
it's like this borderline god-like
figure
in terms of their restraint finds this
monetary technology and releases it to
the world
and pays the price they never took
advantage of their filthy lucr you know
they never
they never recognized any of the 50
billion dollars that they made from
bitcoin
right uh and satoshi also didn't
assign themselves any privileged access
uh to the coins you know satoshi could
have just written in the code
i own ten percent of the coins but they
didn't they just mined
in the open free market competition like
everyone else it's just that
satoshi is an early miner to support the
network
accumulate a lot of coins for sure but
they didn't have any privilege
special access so that's one thing
that's
extremely special about the launch is
that we had a founder
that was truly committed to the monetary
protocol and didn't seek
either recognition or financial spoils
and then also left you know satoshi left
in 2010
2011 and hasn't really been heard from
since it's a very george washington move
gangster move where he didn't want power
and once he got power he let go of it
precisely that was a key
actually move one that was
that was uh probably one of the most
important moves at the founding of this
country
that's right george washington could
have been a king probably if he'd wanted
and satoshi could have been jerome
powell
if he'd wanted and satoshi could have
held on to power
indefinitely but chose to leave the
other thing is that bitcoin
circulated for a long period of time
from january 2009
to about july 2010
without really having a financial value
so
there weren't really any marketplaces it
didn't have a value
and so that gave it this really great
distribution
you know among a broad set of
stakeholders and there were no venture
funds or hedge funds
you know trying to aggressively buy up
all the supply back then
now when you have new cryptocurrencies
launched they're like aggressively
pre-mined and
some gigantic silicon valley venture
fund is going to own 30
of it and so it's sort of impossible to
conceive of how that could become a
global money
because how could you know a
silicon valley investment firm owned 30
of the money supply that doesn't make
sense that's just so
oligarchical right it's unbelievable so
bitcoin by contracts is a very bottom-up
thing
it was the early enthusiasts uh
people that were you know really um
excited about the
technology they're the ones that
obtained those early coins and so
there was a real element of fairness and
just an organic nature to its launch
which would be incredibly hard to
recapture today let's say
satoshi came back and they
said okay i made bitcoin 2.0 i'm going
to release it
there would be the most aggressive land
grab ever
by you know gigantic pools of capital to
sort of get favorable allocations of the
new system
right can satoshi with bitcoin 2.0 build
in
a resistance mechanism or a prevention
mechanism for the land grab
it would be hard to because you know if
you have capital and resources
i mean if it was a proof of work chain
you just have people that would invest a
ton of money in mining for instance
but most new blockchains
cryptocurrencies are just sold
basically they're you know issued in
token offerings kind of thing so
so it's hard to enforce through the
protocol the decentralization of
control yeah power it'd be challenging
too and people have tried to do air
drops
you know where they you know distribute
coins to a large number of people
basically doesn't work
most people don't care about the air
drop so it's hard to have an equitable
distribution
i think the conditions of bitcoin's
launch were so lucky
and favorable that they're very unlikely
to be replicated
so i do think it's going to be real
challenge to ever have a new competitor
that's as decentralized as leaderless as
dispersed sort of distributed as bitcoin
as has its credibility
i don't know how you could overrule it
on those important features
you